at the start of the movie a little girl
and an old man venture out of their home
to get some fresh air however what they
see completely shocks them the city of
london which was sprawling with humans
in traffic just the previous night has
suddenly been covered with a thick
forest the skyscrapers monuments houses
everything has been covered with
gigantic trees that emerged from nowhere
it doesn't take them long to realize
that the final days of humanity have
arrived as nature is taking back what is
theirs in the next scene several news
channels report that the mysterious
trees have not only engulfed london but
the whole world everywhere people are
panicking over the sudden appearance of
the trees and now some countries
including the united kingdom are
planning to burn down the trees to clear
them jamaica says we've been burning
trees for centuries no need to stop now
elsewhere we are introduced to clara and
her boyfriend danny the two are teachers
at a local school and have brought some
of their special students on a museum
sleepover trip after gathering all their
belongings the group decides to head
home one student stops to stare at a
cross-section of a tree on display
noticing that it has a single thick red
ring depicting how many years it grew
clara not knowing what it means simply
guesses that it must have been a good
year to be a tree when they reach the
entrance the guard for some reason fails
to open the door realizing that it is
jammed dany urges the students to help
and finally opens the door however when
they reach outside they are completely
shocked by what they see trees have
taken over the entire city a confused
clara quickly calls the old man from
earlier who is actually doctor who an
alien tasked with rectifying the
anomalies of the universe it turns out
that clara is his accomplice and the two
are known for solving strange mysteries
around the universe she asks the doctor
if he's in the area and he says yes he
further mentions that he is not alone as
a little girl named maebe is giving him
company hearing the name clara becomes
surprised as mabe is one of her students
and she is supposed to be in their group
doctor who is being suss wasting no time
she tells dany about the situation and
the two start blaming each other for
their carelessness as they argue we get
to know that maebe is suffering from
emotional trauma and has regular
medications for it shortly after danny
clara and all the students reach the
doctor's base which is called tardis to
bring back mabe there one of the
students ruby breaks a small branch and
finds out there are no rings in it she
finds it very strange as a tree's age is
determined by its rings one ring equals
one year just then doctor who approaches
them and reveals that the tree has no
rings because it grew overnight just
like all the other ones in the world
dany asserts that it is impossible but
the doctor responds that it is similar
to the ice age which appeared out of
nowhere and decimated the earth in just
a few days he jokingly says welcome to
the tree age welcome
to the tree age oh doctor who following
this the entire group enters tardis
while the adults try to decipher the
situation the kids are busy playing with
the high-end gadgets present inside just
then the doctor comes across someone's
assignment book which has a series of
drawings each page having a picture of
an angry son striking down trees he
demands to know who drew the pictures
and learns that it was none other than
maebe herself soon everyone starts
searching for the little girl but she is
nowhere to be found then clara reveals
that maebe is different from the other
students she hears voices in her head it
all started when her sister went missing
a few months back hearing this the
doctor deduces that maebe knows
something and that she was trying to
explain it all this time the voices she
hears aren't normal voices but someone
or something is trying to contact her
hence she is the only one who can lead
them to the source of the trees when the
doctor asks what the voices say clara
explains that mabe takes medication that
can make the voices go away this angers
the doctor and he shouts that they never
listen to a child he then uses his sonic
screwdriver to get a reading on mabe's
phone following this he and clara set
out to find her while danny and the kids
stay behind in the tardis during the
search a massive statue cracks and falls
on them luckily the two evade just in
time and survive the doctor claims that
if this really is an invasion by nature
they would have won easily and humanity
would be doomed hence he's still
confused on the purpose of the invasion
a while later the two find mabe's cell
phone on the ground and assume that she
is leaving clues for them their
assumptions turn out to be true when
they find her tiffin box and purse along
the way it appears as if the little girl
is trying to lead them somewhere
elsewhere mabe runs across some men in
protective suits who are preparing to
burn down the whole forest for some
reason this scares her and she
immediately changes course and runs away
shortly after the doctor and clara also
arrive at the scene only to be ordered
to vacate the area for their own safety
soon the men ignite their flamethrowers
and start burning the trees surprisingly
not a single leaf burns implying that
the trees are not normal the doctor is
equally dumbfounded by the strange
phenomenon but he deduces that the trees
are controlling the oxygen since fires
do not ignite in the absence of oxygen
the trees are deliberately holding it
back so that they do not burn with this
information the doctor starts exploring
the reasons for the strange occurrence
when he once again checks mabe's drawing
it finally dawns on him that the trees
are not the enemies but they are
actually trying to save the earth from
an impending catastrophe now they have
to find maebe as she is in some way
connected to the trees as the two are
discussing they hear some wolves howling
nearby clara asserts that it is
impossible to have wolves in london but
the doctor assumes that they broke out
of the nearby zoo on the other hand mabe
is spotted by the wolves causing her to
run in terror hearing her screams the
doctor and clara rush to help her they
find her on the other side of a fence
and just as the wolves are about to
attack mabe she spots a gate and reaches
safety however their problems are far
from over as the wolves are easily
capable of jumping the fence with their
lives on the line the doctor instructs
clara and mabe to huddle together and
act like a monster the plan doesn't work
and the wolves jump the fence but
instead of attacking the group they
whimper and run away maebe is left
confused as to why the ferocious beasts
would run away just then a bengal tiger
slowly approaches them from the other
side of the fence this time it appears
as if the group is doomed but luckily
danny and the children arrive in the
nick of time and scare the tiger away as
the two parties reunite and exchange
pleasantries mabe continues acting
strangely it seems like she is swatting
something from her head looking at her
condition ruby pleads with her teachers
to give mabe her medications but the
doctor stops them he mentions that
something is trying to contact mabe and
if she takes the medications she will
stop hearing the voices in her head he
further mentions that the voices may be
instrumental in deciphering the
situation soon mabe runs off again and
everyone pursues her she leads them to a
barren place where there are no trees or
vegetation with everyone's attention on
her mabe reveals that after the
disappearance of her sister annabelle
she started searching for her everywhere
she couldn't find annabelle but what she
did find were several thoughts one of
the thoughts talked about covering the
entire world with dense forest claiming
that it is necessary the doctor inquires
about the source of the thoughts but
little mabe can't give a definite answer
as a result he takes out his sonic
screwdriver and operates it on mabe this
causes the object's irritating mabe to
become visible as sparks of light soon
the lights become still and use mabe to
communicate they reveal that they are
the life force of the trees which have
been on earth for billions of years and
will continue to live for eternity their
duty is to save the earth from external
threats and this time the threat is the
approaching solar flare from the sun
confused the doctor asks the life force
if they sent mabe to him but they deny
it saying this the lights leave freeing
mabe of her sickness later clara
approaches the doctor and inquires if he
can save the world unfortunately he
replies that he can only stop evil
forces not nature with all hopes now
seemingly lost clara proposes an idea to
at least save the children and
themselves by entering the tardis and
transporting to a different direction
however when the group reaches the
tardis she tells the doctor that none of
the kids will be joining them they
simply cannot abandon their parents and
run off to another planet it turns out
that she faked the idea just to get the
doctor back to safety as he is essential
in the timeline not wanting to be alone
the doctor tells clara that earth is his
planet too and asks her to join him
however she also refuses claiming that
she doesn't want to be the last of her
kind with this the sleepover group
departs leaving the doctor alone in the
tardis in the next scene as the doctor
is continuing his research he comes to a
sudden realization that the solar flare
has happened before in the past he then
rushes to meet the group and brings them
back inside the tardis there he explains
that the trees are the real heroes and
that they have been protecting life on
earth for centuries whenever a major
catastrophe hit they sprung up all over
the world to keep it safe from
devastation for instance the tunguska
blast of 1908 and the 1930 karuka impact
in brazil should have wiped humanity but
it didn't this is because the trees all
over the world reunite and neutralize
the threat by controlling the atmosphere
massive forests fill the atmosphere with
oxygen pumping it up like a highly
inflammable airbag as a result when
trouble hits the impact burns off the
excess oxygen so they act as a shield
that protects the earth clara then
points out that the tree they saw
earlier in the museum has a red ring in
its cross section and the red ring is
wider than the others which is proof
that the atmospheric dust was captured
by the tree while saving the earth a
long time ago just then danny reveals
that he heard the government is sending
out teams to defoliate the trees they
will drop extremely poisonous chemicals
onto the leaves and as a result of which
the trees will finally die hearing this
the doctor becomes enraged as humanity
is trying to kill the only element that
is trying to save the earth luckily he
finds that the mobile networks are still
operating and decides to broadcast a
message to the entire earth little mabe
offers to convey the message since she
was the first to receive the news and
the doctor agrees after this the kids
gather around and start composing a
message while the doctor hacks into
every communication device in the world
once everything is set up mabe starts
speaking her speech is heard around the
world advising everyone to be calm and
that the trees are to be left alone as
they serve a benevolent purpose she
tells everyone that the trees are their
friends and that they are here to save
the earth from a disaster so they should
just stay inside their homes and let the
trees do their work before hanging up
she also requests that her sister
annabelle return shortly after the kids
head outside determined to meet their
family since they are not sure if the
earth will be saved they want to spend
the last hours with their loved ones
hearing mabe's message her mother also
arrives outside the tardis and hugs her
tightly before leaving the doctor asks
the kids if they want to watch the solar
flare from space but they refuse only
his companion clara agrees to it but
only after all the kids are returned
home she and danny then share a kiss
which the children laugh at as the
rumors about them dating have been
proven true later the two time travelers
reach space in their tardis and watch
the earth soon the solar flare strikes
and the earth is covered in flames
however according to the doctor's
prediction the trees absorb the
devastation and eventually save earth
later as they look over london the
gigantic trees start crumbling away
clara wonders what will be told about
the trees but the doctor replies that
they will simply be forgotten just like
any story in the past it will simply
become a fairy tale as humankind has one
superpower the power of forgetting
things unless someone filmed it for tick
tock elsewhere mabe and her mom happily
return home after a great day of
adventure just then the little girl
spots someone in a nearby bush and
becomes excited the movie ends as the
bush evaporates into the air exposing
her long-lost sister annabelle subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching